it's time for Comic Con 2014 and here
are the highlights of the coolest things
to do and see Thursday in Hall H Sony
Pictures presents a look at next
summer's releases with Jack Black and
their adaptation of RL stine's
goosebumps and Sony's other big film
pixels starring adam sandler the giver
the famous novel is finally coming to
the big screen at this panel the
weinstein company will premiere
exclusive footage from the upcoming film
with jeff bridges and lois lowry batman
1966 holy comic-con Batman Adam West
Burt Ward and Julie Newmar take the Hall
H stage to talk about the 1960s Batman
TV show and give you a sneak peek at the
exclusive content on the new blu-ray for
Batman the TV series Marvel House of
ideas want to know more about what
marvel comics to read want to know more
about the future of digital comics on
your mobile device then this panel is
for you the editorial director of marvel
and other guests will talk about what's
happening at Marvel Comics toy story
that time forgot ABC and disney pixar
will present an exclusive first look at
the upcoming holiday special for Toy
Story DC Comics all-access DC Comics
gives coverage over what's happening in
the world of DC and what stories you
should be reading comic con how to
advanced inking techniques learn how to
digitally ink and take your artwork to
the next level this session is a
must-see for all aspiring comic artists
Funimation panel Funimation is north
america's largest anime distributor hear
the latest news on properties like
Dragon Ball Z and Akira mad panel the
best selling humor magazine has this
hilarious comic con panel featuring
editors of the magazine who will give
fans the latest news on what's happening
behind the scenes
and those are the highlights for Comic
Con 2014 on Thursday
you